[Music]
[Applause]
Vegas baby the try guys are throwing a
surprise bachelor party for our best
buddy Keith by spending none of our own
money we work for BuzzFeed it is a major
media company and if we can't exploit
that for one of our best friend's
bachelor party what's the point
Keith I'm here and that's Brian that's
your brother say hi no you can't take
the bag off he does no idea what's about
to happen because we were gonna take him
on the biggest most expensive bachelor
party of all time and it's all happening
in Vegas Vegas baby
what happens in Vegas gets put on the
Internet
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
they're playing the track guys are
flying on today's valley that's $6,000
it's okay it's a private jet with an -
got my phone I went beep boop bop beep
got a private jet it's a 15-minute
flight out to Vegas I've been to Vegas
five times I don't remember any of it
I've been to several bachelor parties
but never in Vegas the crown jewel of
dirty guy thing and look who's with us
thanks for getting my private jet look
it is our job as best friends to throw
an absolutely debaucherous weekend
filled with mistakes regrets and
hangovers private jet jet fighter jet so
the first thing that people do when they
find private jet is drink a lot of booze
and take a lot of dumb pictures you
literally delayed the plane 15 minutes
just so we could take pictures you get a
nice crew that's gonna take care of
handling your luggage beautiful airplane
with free booze in it water sodas
even the seatbelts are cold so our
company does a lot of really high
net-worth executives business people
mostly
I've never seen engine actually nervous
under a fella
[Music]
I gotta check out my boys private jet
we'll see you in Vegas
wow we are landing in Las Vegas I don't
care but Nevadans will get upset all of
Vegas looks like different areas of a
theme park not just to try guys on this
bachelor party we got a whole big crew
were rolling with roll call I've got two
of my buddies from Chicago LP and Chris
I got Alex renewing from my comedy
banlieue Berger Brian and Mark who - my
best friend from college who also live
in LA Brothers there try guys are there
and then Chris manages its party I know
it's hard to keep his secret but it's
also hard for me to not be in control as
you can see by me grabbing my shoulder
and stress so Keith we're actually we're
not going to the regular hotel where
there's a private entrance the villas at
the Marah bye bye bye how do we know
it's real if it's a mirage what
[Music]
welcome to the villas at the Mirage
there's only eight places to stay in
this enormous castle and this is this
welcome to your villa
holy [ __ ] let me take you to where the
magic happens very forward Nick oh my
god
so this is one of two bedrooms dual
masters with dual master baths as well
those bathrooms are both bigger than my
apartment
the toilet is a [ __ ] square open
toilet this is our own special women
that we use here yeah different from the
rest of the hotel so the other commoners
don't get this fancy linen not this
fancy just folks like you and me that's
it
all right Nick what are you doing for
the rest of this weekend okay it's mine
and we didn't even get to see the best
part there's the best part
[Music]
there's a tiny pool I did not think my
day would start out with a private jet
if it leads to me being on my underwear
on a duck
it's like gorgeous it's nice being on a
bed that's only six inches off the floor
all of our rooms do come with their own
private butler service we have a
dedicated staff dedicated chef so any
border that you make is coming right
from our kitchen we'll send runners all
across the United States all over the
world sometimes just to pick up special
requests for weight if I wanted like
squirt but I wanted squirt from South
Carolina you do that I would not tell
you know the most expensive soda
offensive words how many places to make
fried chicken you oh we make the best
fried chicken probit so you do flush
their pee you let your pee in there
Chris this is the nicest place with
everybody so we're gonna head to the
bedroom we're gonna make this a two
chicken watch bowling chicken wise
moment go great babe
Oh God why it's like a drug I'm giving
it the sexy now because look at how
about look it's beautiful this is a
month beautiful chicken you never had I
think this is beautiful as Huey
stonefish's right now this is one of the
best I've ever had
chicken watch repertoire biggest
addition circle by small new this is the
first time I'm meeting some of Keith's
friends and if there's this cool thing
happening we're like old friends have
become a new friends and new friends
feel like they're old friends we're all
just one big happy family
comes all over this expensive ottoman I
know that you really like pinball so we
are going to the pinball Hall of Fame
but what give us pinball don't you know
I love people I think my love of pinball
originates from the Sesame Street
pinball intro it's we we all start out
in costumes the way that we think women
might find appealing we work our way
down from there we're gonna teach you a
few dance moves today the key here might
be able to use when he's wedding night
spice things up you know they taught me
a little bit of move so I can impress
Becky in the bedroom on wedding night so
you go one two go around and down like a
ready to poop right on the radio yeah I
got you sorry sorry sorry
there's no sorry there's no sorry's and
that's that sliced FX burn jacket and
then the socket we got all the sexy Ozzy
men I became a sexy Aussie man myself
so I think it's time that you actually
practice practice on someone ready for
you what do you know what do you reckon
uh yeah I can find a good Becky
look-alike
[Laughter]
[Applause]
so I met Keith in 2006 we ended up in
the same improv group in college and I
believe he was playing French horn and
singing some sort of offensive song and
I remember walking away going like that
guy was really funny but I don't know
that's okay this is just what Becky's
hair looks like this is perfect this is
such a close resemblance to my beautiful
bride she'll be thrilled about this
I got to be onstage with the pros
ripping my shirt off among some gorgeous
man and I feel bad for them because I
got a nice torso so uh now what we are
changed and we are ready for yet another
surprise for Keith where are we going
oh you'll see
[Music]
he loves to see his name he loves to
hear his name and Vegas is all about
spraying his name everywhere do you ever
watch like MTV Spring Break this was
that
but in Vegas it felt like a goddamn
music video people are splashing around
everyone's looking hot in bathing suits
we have a private Cabana reserved for us
including bottle service some tasty
snacks and a few keep related surprises
and then they bring fried chicken wings
I mean so much fried chicken it's great
then be taken to DJ booth most people
don't know who I am
so I just start [ __ ] dancing best
part I get to do the fan and I also get
to hit the big button that for some
reason shoots fog out of the DJ everyone
went [ __ ] nuts
this was a lot of bottle service my
favorite memory of Keith is also my
worst memory into the one night we're
talking about the influence of John
Philip Sousa on the culture of America
Keith got so upset stripped naked penis
and balls and everything in front of my
girlfriend and threw that chair of my
apartment right through that beautiful
new screen door that I had
he loves his American watches just when
I think you know it's winding down maybe
we should start heading the entire crew
of bikini clad women come back and
they're like Keith go stand in the pool
I'm like okay great I'll stand in the
pool they literally surrounded him like
a goddamn champagne [ __ ] and just
sprayed it keeps dancing getting
showered in champagne the first five
seconds of like the next 30 seconds or
I'm gonna drown and just what I think
it's done one last lady just bought is
one more bottle directly on in my face
and I'm like who's doing this why would
this happen to me it's supposed to be my
day it was a huge waste of champagne
Vegas baby
that's what kids we're not even close to
done
so what do you do to follow up one of
the most insane pool parties ever time
for the boys to suit up
my name is Jamal Tarzana I'm the
executive chef at libertine social at
Mandalay Bay in Las Vegas we have like
unlimited resources to get any product
on earth here and incredibly fresh it's
almost like the opposite of what happens
in the rest of the country what makes
this restaurant special where everything
is all about like local and sourcing
everything not a lot of food girls in
Las Vegas so we have to get really
creative this is it that's tremendous
third fried chicken of the day Jesus
what Keith doesn't know is that the
signature dish will be prepared by me
the steak is from an American Wagyu cow
that's the same Cal it's used in Kobe
Japan to make Kobe beef hope it tastes
good otherwise I'm like ruining a very
expensive cut of meat there you go just
a super anxious rich delicious almost
like creamy it burns it like 750 degrees
so prepare to be uncomfortable by how
hot it is got the ones all the way in
the back we grow some mushrooms we're
using maitake mushrooms today that gets
tossed in a truffle vinaigrette with a
soy sauce lime juice some radish fresh
herbs if my co-workers Steven Lim taught
me anything it's that this dish needs
Trump
let's do our smoke gun oh yeah get it
baby get it baby
[Music]
police station
okay that's it yeah it's rough
and they were just take this for
recreational yeah I'm Tony abou-ganim
principal mixologist and partner here at
libertine social and I've got something
really special for the groom-to-be it's
our summertime swizzle I'll need a
couple volunteers to help me make up
some pictures there you go up and down
no not like that that yours perfect
looks like his leg next gonna be a
little watered down because the over
swizzle I really thought I was gonna do
a good job
[Music]
[Applause]
I put extra truffles on it for you
bachelor boy I see that I think Ned was
just trying to skyrocket this bill a
little higher and just throw money on
the plate for me to eat
that's so good oh my god that beef is so
good lashya goodness me all be surprises
so far were a little bit of foreplay the
climax though is when we take key to
hide at the lodge we have the best view
in all of Las Vegas this entire section
is ours we have some very good alcohol
coming our way so drink up enjoy the
night is yours my man thank you very
much thank all you guys for making this
so fun I first met Keith in 2009 I have
twin girls Keith and his fiancee Becky
would come over and watch my daughters
every Thursday he spent a lot of time
helping me and just being a good friend
he thinks that this table was his
special treat and he's all excited he's
I'm a good time
then they bring out this $250,000 bottle
of champagne
[Music]
sir bottle Johnny bottle champagne of
course it's view what could be better
then they bring out this like fancy
button looks like a doomsday device this
is the first time I've ever been given a
read but a button that like makes
decisions that affects people's lives
that can change the course of history
so I'd do it any level-headed person
debate I thought he could pick any song
he wanted but Christmas in July I get
maybe that is half a million dollars
we were only paying a quarter so I
picked ho down by Aaron Copland we all
counted down and he gently slapped that
light and the fountains erupted and you
know that below all of Las Vegas was
sharing in our experience we've got to
just have a moment of peace
looking at the fountains it felt like
the end of Ocean's eleven there's like
the most magical moment of my life until
I get married
I think the night's done then we turn
around restaurant has turned into a club
I love parties
in the same place but it looks different
I've got a table there's a screen that
goes up a deejay comes out lights
dancing and it weird all of a sudden a
club and then from there it's a blur we
go [ __ ] hard for the rest of the
night there's lasers everywhere there's
a bridal party and we hang out with them
then we go later bridal party we got
other places to be so then we go to
lights which of course lots of lights we
have another table for some reason we're
just partying to make Keith even more
happy I had a special idea at the club
it's a Keith turn around turn around and
the screens have my name raining down on
them it's like at the end of solitaire
on Windows 95 when all the cards like
bounce everywhere senators just keep he
was so happy it was just it was all
worth it and then we go to hackathon
Hakkasan was just another planet and
Tiesto and baby CJ - zj's so we're
dancing they gave us these bracelets
that light up the whole crowd lights up
I feel depleted I didn't sleep enough I
think I think babies took a little part
of me thought it said this is minor when
you were in Las Vegas you get to feel
like you're royalty it is a city
designed to make you feel awesome and to
allow you to live in a fantasy if only
for a day
it was a special experience because it
was all about Keith and it was about
friendship it was about Brotherhood cuz
we loved Keith you know Keith is is such
an amazing performer such an amazing guy
keith is a great person to collaborate
with to hang out with to be friends with
I'd encourage him to keep his spirit of
improvisation and a spirit of
spontaneity I think the most important
thing he can do in his marriage is find
the tons that Becky's in the star I
think Keith doesn't need that much
advice he's very good with relationships
everybody likes Keith I think he's gonna
be great
now Keith's gonna be married I'm also
married and I you gene has dogs so like
I've I need a thing guess I gotta have a
baby or something